oh
[Musique]
et pour en parler nous sommes avec
sébastien huyghe débuté les républicains
de la 5e circonscription du nord bonsoir
avons continué joaquim pueyo maire ps
d'alençon président de la communauté
urbaine d'alençon ancien député bonsoir
merci messieurs d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors l'assemblée a
rétabli aujourd'hui au 16 février
l'échéance de la provocation d'état
d'urgence sanitaire hier les députés les
diverses oppositions avaient passé un
amendement fixant la fin de l'état
d'urgence au 14 décembre
comment est ce que vous comprenez cette
cacophonie comment se fait-il que les
députés n'arrivent pas à faire bloc sur
cette question d'urgence sanitaire selon
vous joaquim pueyo ajouté hier il ya eu
effectivement un problème ça arrive
quelques fois que la majorité ne soit
pas au rendez vous lorsqu'il ya des
amendements aussi important qui avaient
été déposés par les républicains
chacun chaque groupe s'est positionné il
ya des groupes qui étaient plus tôt pour
revoir ses conditions au mois de
décembre d'autres au mois de février
donc la majorité pour le mois de février
je pense que c'est tout à fait normal
que le fait majoritaire dans un
parlement l'amp hors de moi ça me choque
pas que le gouvernement a demandé un
nouveau vote
voilà parce que la majorité elle est
quand même présente donc voila mais ceci
dit l'opposition avait une autre une
position concernant les dates mais
cependant je constate quand même que la
deuxième vague est très forte moi je
bois sur les territoires de plus en plus
de deux personnes sont hospitalisées les
services de réanimation sont très
tendues et moi je pense aux enseignants
et je pense que le confinement me paraît
indispensable comme d'ailleurs parfois
sur certains territoires les couvre feu
si on nous démontre que depuis qu'on
avait ni couvre feu dans les grandes
métropoles
la tendance est à la baisse je pense ça
vaut le coup quand même d'y réfléchir
sébastien huyghe député les républicains
certains hommes la circonscription du
nord
effectivement face à cette perspective
d'une dynamique de hausse des cas de
contamination
quelle est votre position à ce qu' il
faut effectivement d'aller plus loin que
ce confinement que nous vivons en ce
moment
est-ce qu'il faut effectivement que
l'état d'urgence sanitaire soit
prolongée jusqu'au 6 février
comme l'a acté d'ailleurs le
gouvernement aujourd'hui quel est votre
regard sur ce cap
en fait nous avions fait un a adopté un
amendement puisque la majorité était
absente finalement de l'hémicycle a été
ultra minoritaire ça voulait dire
d'abord que les députés en marche qui
était absent il n'était pas intéressé
comme il le fallait par ce texte qui est
important pour l'avenir de nos
concitoyens et nous avions fait adopter
un amendement qui permettait de mettre
de fixer la fin de l'état d'urgence
à la mi décembre c'était pas pour dire
que l'état d'urgence allaient s'arrêter
à la mi-décembre mais simplement c'était
une clause de revoyure comme on dit pour
que le gouvernement fasse un point
d'étape à ce moment là pour voir s'il
fallait continuer l'état d'urgence ou
l'arrêter parce que nous estimions que
comme le voulait le gouvernement
et eux ils voulaient six mois tranquille
sans s'en venir rendre des comptes au
parlement et donc nous estimions que
c'était beaucoup trop long et qu'il y
avait besoin régulièrement de revenir
devant le parlement qui est le
représentant du peuple français pour
définir et répondre aux questions pour
définir la stratégie et répondre aux
questions des parlementaires ce qui
était somme toute légitime
ensuite nous avons défendu des
amendements qui n'ont pas été entendus
pour permettre aux commerces de
proximité de pouvoir ouvrir dans cette
période qui n'est pas une période de
confinement une vraie période de
confinement nous l'avons vécu à
l'occasion de la première vague mais ce
que nous vivons aujourd'hui où les
entreprises sont ouvertes où les écoles
les collèges les lycées les transports
en commun tout fonctionne à peu près
normalement on ne peut pas considérer
que ce soit un confinement c'est plutôt
une restriction importante de
circulation
aucun véritable confinement et dans ce
cadre nous ne comprenions pas alors que
toutes les entreprises étaient ouverts
et bien que certains petits commerces de
centre-ville parfois de villes ou de
villages étaient fermés il y avait une
distorsion de concurrence notamment par
rapport un certain nombre de plateformes
on commet de vente par correspondance de
plates formes numériques tels amazon qui
eux peuvent vendre tout et n'importe
quoi à tous nos concitoyens partout sur
le territoire donc il y avait besoin de
remettre de la cohérence dans ce que
proposait joaquim pueyo vous comprenez
effectivement que beaucoup dénoncent ce
paradoxe donc à la fois d une hausse de
la contamination des chiffres en hausse
et puis de l'autre côté une vie je
dirais pas normal mais quasi normal on
peut aller travailler on croise pas mal
de monde finalement dans la rue
finalement ce paradoxe cela que beaucoup
dénoncent
est ce qu'il doit le gouvernement doit
finalement taper plus fort avec par
exemple un couvre-feu qui a été annoncé
je tiens quand même à rappeler que dans
dans les départements ruraux comme dans
les villes moyennes le confinement est
respecté dans l'ensemble on ne voit pas
beaucoup de monde dans les rues
d'alençon une agglomération de 60000
habitants
je voudrais répondre à mon ancien
collègue je suis d'accord avec lui
lorsque il dit effectivement il ya eu
une incompréhension
parce que les commerçants on considérait
qu'il y avait pas une akali une égalité
de traitement dès vendredi dernier
j'adressais d'ailleurs moi même un
courrier au premier ministre pour que y
ait une égalité de traitement sur les
points de vente entre les grandes
surfaces et les commerces de proximité
ça a été relayée d'ailleurs par
l'association france urbaine qui
regroupe les métropoles et les
communique belle nous avons demandé
également cédé qualité traitement en
partie on a été entendu mais la question
de fond qu'on doit se poser dans quel
endroit on est le plus contaminé tous à
la question qu'il faut se poser
effectivement quand je regarde toutes
les petits commerçants qui peuvent
accueillir un ou deux clients n'auraient
pu d'ailleurs faire une
un dispositif pour permettre
effectivement à des petits commerçants
s'ouvrir et d'accueillir très peu de
clients pour respecter les conditions
sanitaires alors que dans les grandes
surfaces
vous avez des centaines de personnes qui
peuvent être sur un même rayon
donc c'est vrai il ya un sujet qui se
pose moi j'écoute et comme je suis
président d'un conseil de surveillance
au niveau de l'hôpital j'écoute
également mes médecins qui me disent
monsieur le maire la situation est très
tendue
il faut absolument favoriser le complot
le confinement est pas un confinement là
donc on a ces deux versions le
gouvernement a choisi une version
confinement en dix ans pour que
l'économie fonctionne toujours là c'est
vrai qu'il ya des contradictions
moi en tant que mère par exemple je n'ai
pas voulu faire des arrêtés pour ouvrir
les commerces parce que j'estimais cdd
d'arrêter illégaux
j'ai préféré faire un courrier au
premier ministre comme avec
l'association france urbaine pour
demander effectivement ils ont des
évolutions qui a eu un premier pas le
ministre de l'économie des finances je
sais pas si il tiendra parole mais je
les écoute il est très prudent et je
peux le comprendre a indiqué aux
fédérations qui réunit revoyure dans
quinze jours j'attends cette revoyure si
effectivement on nous démontre que la
pandémie se stabilise
là où il ya effectivement un confinement
si on ne démontre que effectivement si
on ouvre les commerces
il n'y aura pas d'incidence sur la
pandémie
la réflexion mérite d'être d'être fait
et des décisions seront prises sébastien
est-ce qu'il faut selon vous aujourd'hui
taper plus fort une bonne fois pour
toute c'est à dire tout verrouiller tout
fermer les écoles les transports comme
au premier confinement finalement pour
mettre un bon coup d'arrêt à cette
pandémie
moi je ne suis pas spécialiste
infectiologues
je ne suis pas médecin et je n'ai pas
les chiffres en direct comme peut
l'avoir le gouvernement c'est au
gouvernement de prendre la décision sur
ce qu'il considère comme le meilleur
moyen de protéger nos concitoyens par
contre en tant que responsable politique
j'observe que
les mesures que son prix qui sont prises
manque de cohérence
c'est à dire qu'à partir du moment où on
accepte et on considère que nos
concitoyens peuvent aller dans un
supermarché faire leurs courses
je ne vois pas la différence et le
risque supplémentaire qui existent
lorsque sur les rayons ce sont des
boîtes de conserve et lorsque sur les
rayons ce sont des bois des jouets et
des boîtes de jeux pour préparer les
fêtes de noël
je considère que à partir du moment où
on les laisse aller dans des
supermarchés
pourquoi est-ce que chez le petit
commerçant dans nos villes dans nos
centres villes et dans nos bourgs dans
nos villages
et bien si un protocole sanitaires
strictes et mise en place pourquoi on ne
leur permet pas d'ouvrir et puis et il
n'y a qu'à faire un certain nombre de
contrôles et s'il ya un certain nombre
de commerçants ne respectent pas ces
protocoles sanitaires qui doivent être
strict et bien ils se feront l'objet
d'une fermeture administrative
le problème pour moi c'est le manque de
cohérence dans l'es6 ion dans les
décisions du gouvernement et on a vu
hier soir un ministre de la santé qui a
perdu ses nerfs qui a perdu pété les
plombs excusez moi de l'expression mais
c'est véritablement sur la quoi nous
avons assisté hier parce qu'il le semble
dépassé par la situation
tout cela parce qu'il ya eu un manque
d'anticipation à la fin de la première
vague
tous les spécialistes médecins nous ont
prévenu qu'il y aurait à l'automne une
seconde vague la seconde vague
hélas hélas rien qui puisse dire c'est
que nous n'étions pas prêts il n'y a pas
eu de stratégie mise en oeuvre est ce
que nous ressentons c'est que les
décisions sont prises dans la
précipitation au fil de l'eau et non par
rapport à un plan stratégique prévu à la
vente
monsieur le maire le mot de la fin il
nous reste quelques secondes s
qu'effectivement vous selon vous vous
partagez ce constat qu de sébastien lui
que le gouvernement est en train de
perdre pied face à la situation
non je ne dirais pas qu'on gouvernement
perd pied parce qu'effectivement le
gouvernement s'attendait pas une
deuxième vague aussi forte
d'ailleurs quels sont les pays qui
s'attendaient à une dixième pas 9e pack
aussi fort voyez ce qui s'est passé en
italie qui s'est passé en espagne des
pays qui ont été très touchés ils ont
été également comme nous c'est à dire
qu'ils ont pas considérer y aurait une
deuxième vague très porte d'ailleurs y
avait des combines et plus vite que nous
d'ailleurs
et effectivement des mois de septembre
et beaucoup d'inquiétude certains pays
ont pris des décisions dont je crois que
le coc vide c'est c'est un virus
effectivement qui a dépassé tout le
monde y compris
écoutez moi j'écoutais des spécialistes
au mois d'avril au mois de mai qui
disait n'y aurait pas de deuxième vague
le vérisme mais quelques grands
spécialistes dont vous connaissez leurs
noms qu'on fait la une des médias
aiguille on entend du président du
comité scientifique dire au mois de juin
il y aurait une deuxième vague lui-même
reconnaît qu'ils pensaient pas que la
deuxième vague aussi forte
effectivement la tête des comptines et
trop rapidement moi par exemple en tant
que maire dès le mois de juillet je vais
être obligé de vous couper est ce qu'on
arrive au terme du temps qui nous est
imparti en un monde de porter les
masques
lorsqu'on est pas le rendent obligatoire
mais j'avais fait cette recommandation
et je pense qu'il fallait effectivement
rendu obligatoire le port du masque
comme ils reconnurent est depuis
généralisé également les cours au sol il
ya déjà plus d'un mois merci beaucoup à
tous les deux mr sy joaquim pueyo maire
ps d'alençon président de la communauté
urbaine d'alençon ancien député merci à
vous sébastien huyghe député l'est
républicain certes 5e circonscription du
nord